you
when I first met Larry my first
impression was very Larned very
passionate very committed to education
very committed to our country Larry is
he has obviously this intellectual side
he doesn't hit you over the head with
his intellect but boy when you engage
him it's fascinating it it can be a
seminar but he he does it with such
passion and he does it with such not
just knowledge but almost emotional
involvement with the subject that it
makes it really palatable really
interesting and he's a fascinating how
to be with dr. Ahrens students they
loved him and they fear him one of his
favorite activities is to go into the
dining hall sit down at a table of
students he hasn't met yet and then just
start grilling them you'd think its
intellectual boot camp he considers them
colleagues because unless people are
partners in this intellectual venture
that he's in charge of they won't
actually benefit from it Larry's voice
is still powerful because he brings the
Constitution the Declaration and their
principles to everyday working Americans
he's always working hard to educate the
next generation of Patriots at Hillsdale
and that's because he so firmly believes
in America and believes in the cause
that he's defending if he's talking
about the founding if he's talking about
the Constitution or the Declaration of
Independence it's not an intellectual
exercise for him I mean it is very
personal and very emotional and it can't
help but involve you in in what you're
talking about and it's great to see that
I know his students respond to it I know
I do Larry is definitely the smartest
guy in the room whenever I'm in the room
with him but he's also again the son of
hard-working parents in Northeast
Arkansas who's never forgotten his roots
Larry iron is an avid sportsman loves to
shoot clays go pheasant hunting and one
of my very fond recollections is his
invitation to me and my two sons to come
and join him in a pheasant hunt you know
it is it is actually a little
nerve-wracking when you've got the
chairman of the board and the president
of the college and two inexperienced
boys holding shotguns you go oh this
could go wrong in so many ways
the Bradley prize has always highlighted
the work of Americans who are dedicated
to the principles on which this country
was founded individual rights limited
and constitutional government and
Larry's life has been dedicated network
and Larry brings those principles to
life in so many different ways that
Americans can understand and they can
relate to his position is one of let's
say call it a voice of political
conscience remember what you are about
in this great Republic do not let
yourself get lost in the chaos of
contemporary political noise return to
principles founding principles always
keep those that that's the kind of
position he has Larry arns reach it will
go on for generations because he has
helped train young minds who are really
making a difference in this country
you